so let's start with the bronze medal
winner with his film the compositor
bronze medal honors this evening go to
director John mateusz e John before I
start I just wanted to tell my mother
one thing even though i didn't win the
gold i'm still going to buy you that
house in Beverly Hills ok I just wanted
to thank the Academy you've been awesome
thank you for bringing us to a
fantabulous restaurant last night where
I had a chance to meet a lot of the
committee from the Academy the governors
and whoever else is associated with the
student the academies you guys were all
pretty awesome I imagined you to have
giant horns and sharp teeth coming out
here from New York but you're actually
were very gentle very kind very
inspiring and thanks for changing my new
york mentality about you guys I no
longer think your goblins and monsters
also thank you to all you awesome
filmmakers I've been to a lot of
festivals in the past couple years and
I've actually never been to a festival
where I liked every film and you guys
are awesome really amazing talented kids
and I'd love to work with you in the
next 10-15 years also wanted to thank my
casting crew especially the ones that
brought together the crazy cast alexa
alexa de cambio my mail muse donald
point nur none of these people are here
and eric bronco my DP for basically
taking control of the the entire film
while i was on the other side trying to
perform in it and also to my three
guardian angels also known as the three
wise woman one of them is Annie Bonnie
who's been my mentor for 15 years she's
been inspiring educational taught me all
the good things that I need to know to
be a good man as well as I can't read
their names um simona fungal who put up
with a lot of crap during the two years
and as well Jennifer shellhorn who was
my associate producer who was basically
filling the holes in my head with sanity
um and that's about it so thank you guys
so much